[Music]
[Music]
Oh God hey possum I'm sorry just you in
that chair I think that would have made
a damn fine president you would have
brought a real dignity to the office
you're welcome America
welcome to Zombieland
life is about more than just survival we
were a family dysfunctional sure but
what family isn't very what would you
like little girl I really like for you
to stop calling me little girl but you
know what I would like I don't give a
[ __ ] what you it felt so good to be on
the move again
oh my god I'm so sorry hi I'm Columbus
nothing this is telling us II hey paul
blart this your dad
Oh whoopsie I forgot this he thought
wrong oh so she knows the rules I told
him just a few of him
7300 and are there more you're cute will
I get my sister is caught she picked up
a boy he's from Berkeley Berkeley you
have weed Dave do I look like the type
of person that would have weed I'm sorry
whoo-yah have nothing against hippies I
just want beat the [ __ ] out of we're
gonna go get her we write it down start
talking you first
[Music]
[Music]
right oh my apologies little Elvis is it
me or does he kind of remind you of I
don't like you at all
I think you're double-parked Oh more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get a
ticket it's going on here
what hello everyone by listening
[Music]